I think I know this city better than
just about anybody well but I mean are
you really sure about that you haven't
lived here in a while does it matter
Andy what I'm saying is nobody in the
world knows more about New York City
than this guy right here really a yellow
cone and then you should have no trouble
passing the just invented New York City
citizen citizenship test administered by
none other than a Minnesota senator who
was born right here in New York City
senator Al Franken
[Applause]
[Music]
I get a Conan Conan okay it's true I was
born in New York City but I moved to
Minnesota when I was four years old okay
so I just wanted to make it and I'm an
American first okay a Minnesotan second
a Jew third a Hillary supporter for and
of course a reformed Jew fifth but I
love this to love this town so I'm
qualified to administer this test I do
not fear your tests senator al let's do
it okay hmm what are New York City's two
most popular nicknames the Big Apple and
the city that never sleeps
according to Frank Sinatra if you can
make it here you can make it anywhere
what does every slice of pizza in New
York City have in common
every single one of them is world's
famous
what iconic tourist attraction weighs
225 tongues and was a gift from France
Gerard Depardieu what's a good slogan
for the rentable City Bikes throughout
New York City City Bikes isn't it time
you were hit by a crosstown bus you are
correct sir thank you sir
who is LaGuardia Airport named after
mayor LaGuardia who believed that
baseball is much more fun if it's
constantly being interrupted by loud
airplanes where where do the nets play
basketball you call that plane
the frick museum contains a ton of
frickin art name the five boroughs in
New York City wealth town hipster Ville
sweatsuit Heights Goomba Island and the
ESPN Zone name three shows that
originated in the 90s that captured the
feminine voice of New York City Sex in
the City the view and Late Night with
Conan O'Brien
at any given moment in New York City
what's happening Alec Baldwin is picking
a fight with a police horse in 1626
Native Americans were cheated out of
Manhattan in a deal with a Dutch
colonists named Donald van der Trump
the Great White Way is the nickname for
the Trump campaign
in eight words or less can you name the
place where I was born
while pandering to this crowd New York
City the greatest city on earth
[Applause]
you